hello and thanks for joining us for
today's broadcast I'm dr. Garrett Snyder
for March RDX and I'll be moderating the
webinar today before we start there are
a few instructions we want to hear from
you during this broadcast so please ask
questions and leave comments by hitting
the green Q&A button at the lower left
of the presentation and we'll get to as
many as we can after the presentation
and if we don't get to them then we'll
we'll follow up after that after the
broadcast do you want to make it make
the slides look better you can enlarge
the slides window by clicking on the
screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you can't
hear or see the presentation prosody let
us know by again clicking on the Q&A
button or you can click on the support
support button on the on the top right
we'll make sure to resolve any issues
now this is an educational webinar and
this offers free continuing education
credits after the webinar is over please
click on the C e button located in the
bottom left hand corner of your webpage
and follow the process of obtaining your
credits now about our speakers Jonathan
dues to the product manager Archer DX
into grad school at the University of
California Riverside and his expertise
in autoimmune diseases he joined our
r2dax about a year ago josh is the chief
scientific officer and general manager
here at Archer DX
he went to grad school at the University
of Colorado here in Boulder and has been
with r2dax practically from its founding
in he is overseeing the development of
the reagents and software and continues
to lead new application development on a
personal note these two guys are up late
and in early working to constantly
improve an already very powerful
combination targeted enrichment
chemistry and biomedic software and I
think that their passionate commitment
to to precision medicine is less that
they want to push the about the status
quo forward and it shows in and in the
in Archer reveal CTD today and with that
I'll turn
I'm over to Jonathan thanks Jared and
everyone tuning in to join us for what
we hope will be an informative and
helpful discussion about the potential
for detecting mutants CT DNA fragments
from liquid biopsy samples and The
Associated challenges with extracting
meaningful sequence information from
this highly fragmented DNA template pipe
so I imagine probably everyone has seen
this figure by now but we included here
again because it demonstrates quite
nicely
both the CT DNA from many solid tumor
sites can be detected in plasma but also
that the number of CT DNA fragments
detectable using droplet digital PCR is
highly variable across sites and within
samples from the same site in general it
appears that the detectable relative
abundance of mutant fragments and plasma
increases with stage of disease but not
always this publication also reported
that CT DNA fragments were detected less
than half the time in samples from early
stage disease suggesting that either
droplet digital PCR is an inadequate
technology for this template and what is
actually president sample is being
underreported or underlying biology is
complex and there is no negative
predictive value for assays using this
type of template material on the plus
side this data does suggest that CT DNA
fragments are detectable at least half
the time and maybe this template could
be leveraged to potentially identify and
adequately characterize oncogenic driver
mutations either in conjunction with or
in place of FFPE samples or the
monitoring of tumor evolution over time
in other
literature we see the variants
identified from FFPE samples are awesome
concordant was plasma but not always and
this could be particularly exciting when
we think that perhaps this disparity is
potentially due from clonal
heterogeneity maybe an FFPE
cross-section is fundamentally less
representative of overall tumor biology
than circulating CT DNA fragments for
providing a complete picture of the
overall mutation profile of individual
cancers in this diagram here illustrates
that acquired resistance to targeted
kinase inhibitors is confirmed only
after disease progression rather than to
tenth potentially being discovered early
through repeated sampling and actively
monitoring relative proto-oncogenes for
emergent clones and digital PCR is
something that we we hear about very
frequently with this application and
it's great in terms of providing
sensitive detection of low-frequency
mutations from minimal DNA mass inputs
however assays are limited to known
variants and individual assays have
limited target multiplexing capability
and is therefore not as well suited for
detecting or adequately adequately
characterizing clonal emergence so in
our opinion the ideal molecular assay
should provide accurate detection of a
broad range of oncogenic mutations with
literal little or no prior knowledge it
should provide sensitive and reliable
assay performance with limited amounts
of highly fragmented DNA and the data
needs to be reliable and have the
ability to expertly analyze the data
with user-friendly tools so today we're
going to be talking about an archer
targeted in
yes si for a very specific application
and these these products are
manufactured for research use only and
are not to be used in diagnostic
procedures but overall an archer assay
begins with a patented chemistry called
anchored multiplex PCR which we'll learn
more about later today and this is
integrated into a simplified easy to use
library preparation kit with single-use
reaction that are lieth alized and
color-coded supporting a variety of
different applications and they are
configured into a tube strips to easily
support multi-channel pipetting and all
of this is tied together with Archer
analysis which leverages the unique
sequence information from archers
molecular barcode adapters to provide a
very high resolution analysis of NGS
data so this is what the products
actually look like they come in these
eight tube strips and they're very
configurable for a variety of
throughputs being able to break off as
many tubes as you need and store the
rest back in the refrigerator and you'll
also notice that this is a very fast
workflow the amount of time that you're
actually going to have a pipette in your
hands and be interacting with the
product is quite low and it allows
library preparation to be done in a
single day
with less than an hour of total hands-on
time
and now josh is going to tell us about
all of the challenges associated with CT
DNA and how the reveal CT DNA chemistry
overcomes these great thanks Jonathan so
hey everyone out there so what I'll talk
about is kind of the process that we
went through in developing this product
well I think it's important some of the
cool things we've done in the
bioinformatics and to address a lot of
the common issues that you see from
high-throughput sequencing data so I
think the easiest thing to start with is
to kind of frame the question and the
question is okay so what is it that we
are interrogating right so if you think
about cell 3 which there's a certain
population within your blood stream
already this is naturally shed through
natural cell progression whether you
know cells are apoptosis Anette cetera
but there's also circulating tumor DNA
so circulating tumor DNA tends to be of
a small or molecular weight typically
around 150 160 base pairs and that's
because those short strands of DNA are
wrapped around the nucleosomes and
they're protected whilst in bloodstream
so what you can do it you can extract
those pieces of circulating tumor DNA
and you can look at them for mutations
of interest via you know single
nucleotide variant insertion deletions
etc well the problem is is that it's a
very small fraction of the total
circulating cell free DNA within your
bloodstream so the question is how do
you find it so I mean that comes to the
challenges and before we talk about how
we go about finding it so the fragments
are short so if you look over here to
the right hand side what this is just a
fake gel that comes off the
electropherogram that comes off of like
I had to run bio analyzer or a fragment
analyzer I forget which one we using a
lot these days but where you have on the
y-axis is the so this the time point or
the associated base pairs and you'll see
this tight band around 150 160 base
pairs so that is what is inferred or
what is believed to be the circulating
tumor fraction right so that's the
fragments that you want to interrogate
you need to be able to preferentially
capture these
and because they're very short they lack
a lot of contextual information right
you can't rely on a two kilobase long
fragment to map it back to the genome
which creates its own set of challenges
often you get very small input
quantities so you can see it's a very
faint bandwidth in this gel right so if
you only have 20 molecules to put in and
you want to find something at one to a
thousand that's actually not possible
right because you can't find you know a
needle in a haystack if the haystack is
too small or you can't find the needle
if the needle isn't present within the
haystack so really this heavily diluted
background so the other thing is you get
this high molecular weight genomic DNA
and then you get the natural cell
progression that happens throughout your
body in general regardless if you're a
cancer patient and not so you have this
high wild type background of circulating
tumor d or circulating self redeeming so
what I need to look for is we need to
find that circulating tumor DNA within
that background so that presents its own
challenges for variant callers and other
things like that so what we developed at
Archer was what we're calling reveal CT
DNA chemistry so if we think about how
this works it actually works for those
familiar exactly like the rest of our
chemistry we've done a lot of
optimization via things like adapter
ligation and MTCR to increase our
capture efficiency to make sure we
capture as many of those molecules that
we put into the assay as possible but
generally speaking it's the same that we
do for all of our anchored multiplex PCR
technology platforms so you take
circulating tumor DNA or your cell free
CD or fill free fraction you put that
into the tube at that point you do an
end repair and a DA tailing this
prepares it for adapter ligation
so this is where amp becomes unique in
which we like eight on an adapter that
contains a molecular barcode so what
this does is twofold so it creates a
random starts idea that ligation event
so if you think about the population of
nucleic acid around the Buried of
interest it follows with likely a
Gaussian distribution so if you look at
that Gaussian distribution and then you
log it on you have many different start
positions along the genome around you
of interest which gives you one piece of
contextual information then you take
that molecular barcode and that further
helps you disambiguate the number of
molecules present so what that means is
instead of you know our eight mer NB c--
only being 64,000 different combinations
it allows you to have tens of millions
of different unique molecular tags that
allows you to take something post
amplification and compress it back to
represent the input quantity or the
input complexity that was captured prior
to any manipulation so that it looks
like after adapter ligation then you do
some a few rounds of nested PCR so you
take your gene specific primer you
extend along the template strand in the
direction of interest being on the
positive or the negative strand and then
once you've made that copy it creates
the p5 primer binding site in the case
of Illumina this gives me the a primer
binding site if you're using Y on
torrent platform or agnostic 2 platform
in that respect that creates an amplicon
you can then do exponential
amplification this has been followed
into a subsequent PCR in which you do a
nested step so this nested PCR in for
specificity it allows you to get rid of
all that background so you get very high
on target percentage it also attaches
the remaining sequencing bits be it the
P adapter and emulsion PCR end or the p7
flow cell adapter and the kids would be
Illumina platform from there you have
sequencing letter ready library and
there's like Jonathan was mentioning all
this happens and you know very quick
single day workflow so that you can
beyond the sequence of same day so it's
really the first advantage that this
gives you having this single primer
binding site where you don't need to
worry about having to amplicor two
primers having to sit down within a
piece of nucleic acid is that it's
highly tuned for highly degraded
material which is great in the case of
circulating tumor DNA and I think what's
really great about you know where we
started when we went after CT DNA is
that it was purpose-built for FFPE
originally but FFP is highly degraded
and this really translated well so if
you think about a region of interest
which is here in blue and then you have
this blue square this blue square
represents let's call it our bearing of
interest so what we do is we put primers
on both the positive and the negative
strand and what it looks like in sort of
a way is it looks like you're creating
an ample cone however then through the
melting step in the adapter ligation
what you're doing is you're separating
the positive and the negative strand and
you're like getting on this adapter so
when this adapter is like it and on what
you're doing is you're creating the
reverse primer binding site therefore
you only need one of these two primers
to bind on the template of interest to
create an amplicon so in the case of
this cartoon model you get a hundred
percent capture of this region of
interest or this area of interest
because we can capture these very
degraded areas where we maybe only get
the positive strand but you know when we
lose a negative strand or vice-versa in
the case of an amplifier based method
this is actually a huge limitation in my
opinion in the sense that you need both
primer binding sites to be able to pull
out that region of interest if you just
get one of course a bit dropout it won't
go exponential even if it does perform
linear amplification so there's actually
a lot of caveats to that and in the case
of this cartoon model which we actually
generated in silico model for is that
you lose most of these fragments due to
that limitation now if we think about
that in the case so let's apply this to
a real statistical model is that with
traditional amplicons short fragments
are a huge issue so if we look like I
was mentioning earlier and let's assume
a fragment size of around 125 base pairs
and that's around a normal distribution
then we look at the fraction of bases
recovered on the Y versus the amplicon
size so if we assume that we have a 60
base pair amplicon we want to make this
thing very short and to put that into
context a 60 base pair amplicon also
includes both primer binding sites so
that's honestly 40 base pairs of primer
binding site probably at a minimum and
then 20 of contexts that you can
actually use in map so you can imagine
the difficult
together from a bioinformatics
standpoint and even then you're still
looking at about 53 percent of those
Aryan containing fragments are actually
captured from the population and then of
course if you want more sequence context
that you are certain it's correct
because it does not it can't be silenced
by a primer binding site and you go
upwards to 100 base pair fragment well
you get it you're only getting around 21
percent of those fragments are actually
able to be captured let alone the
percentage that are actually captured
from them and that's highlighted here in
this IgD screenshot from EGFR exon 19
you'll see all of these gaps and
coverage and there's a lot of you know
issues with that in particular so what
we did it Archer was we engineered the
reveal CT DNA to capture highly
fragmented material and what we also set
out to do like I was mentioning earlier
is that we only want to capture the
circulating tumor DNA fraction we don't
want contaminating G DNA that arises
from the white blood cells red dot cell
lysis something that happens during the
extraction procedure etc so what that
means is even if we have very clean
extraction and we have 0.1% allelic
fraction within that population we want
that to represent point 1 percent on the
sequencer and the same happens if we
have a high percentage of contaminating
genomic DNA if at that point 1% we want
to measure it at 0.1% within that
population and there's a few different
reasons that you want to do that and you
know one of the reasons is pre analytic
so you want to make sure that as you're
you know processing through the workflow
you don't want to have to worry about oh
was the you know plasma sample that I'm
receiving was a process perfectly was it
process quick enough so that there's no
worry about there being high molecular
Jeannie and among other reasons which
I'll get into in Sarah's briefly so if
we think about this in the context of a
cartoon model really like how do we
enrich for those small molecular weight
fragments and really ant was
suited for this and it actually worked
out quite well is that we're able to
just leverage PCR to solve this problem
for us so if you think about two
different populations you have
circulating tumor day and you have your
high molecular weight G DNA these gray
arrows represent primers which are
sitting down along the template strand
the different colored boxes here on the
end represent our unique molecular
barcode indices and this line represents
our variant of interest so now when you
take this the first thing you'll see is
that if we go through and we amplify all
this in the same tube is that all of
your circulating tumor DNA because it's
relatively small around 160 base pairs
given our PCR reaction conditions will
amplify very well so we'll get multiple
copies of all of these different things
within these unique molecular bins these
blue or sorry these green X's will
represent sequencing error and then our
true variant of interest so amplify all
of those be large kilobase long
fragments just simply due to PCR
selection in sequence of selection we'll
just never make it through into the
sequencing data so these actually weed
themselves out naturally without having
to do any you know molecular biology
tricks or anything along those lines to
actually deplete them now on the case of
highly degraded or that your primer
binding site happens to be toward the
end of a large G DNA fragment these will
get some amplification but it's actually
drastically reduced now the problem with
traditional amplicon libraries if you
think about things I'm using opposing
PCR is that it doesn't really matter if
it's a hue or a very large template
versus a very small template and the
reason is is that both primer binding
sites it's down your affinity for the
circulating tumor DNA is actually
exactly the same as it is for the
genomic DNA so you actually amplify all
of these and what that hurts is your
allelic fraction so what that means is
so you get the truth or the truth within
that cell fraction that you want to
interrogate because that's where it is
believed that we've today in the
literature that that's where the
circulating tumor DNA resides then you
have an opposing PCR method so you have
0.1%
let's just say this is within your
bloodstream use an example if you have a
very clean extraction because your
protocols within the hospital or your
you know not a reference lab and you
don't have to worry about these samples
coming from all over the world sure it
will give you a tight representation
most likely of what the underlying
frequency is within that circulating
tumor DNA population however in the case
of contaminating genomic DNA what will
happen is you'll actually get a lilyc
frequency that is much lower than what
you're trying to find within the
population and this creates issues right
so the issue there is that you actually
have to have better variant callers and
better sensitivity to do the same exact
thing that you could do by just having a
better library prep technology so let's
look at that in practice right so what
we did here is we took HD 780 so this is
horizon control with a known frequency
of circulating tumor DNA mutations right
via like an EGFR mutation etc I believe
it's a cocktail specific mutations and
when you run that with an amplicon based
NGS what you'll see is what we expected
here is if we had HD 280 only is we get
that 5% unreal fraction that we were
hoping to write then we took that same
exact sample and what we did is we put
in a 4x excess of high molecular weight
wild-type DNA so this is let's just say
something like genome in a bottle it's
you know high molecular weight it's
relatively intact because it was
extracted from cells and then what
you'll quickly notice is using the
amplicon technology is that this easy 5%
variant call is now coming down around
1% so this variant call that was
actually should be relatively easy it's
now becoming relatively difficult and it
becomes difficult from an informatics
standpoint and you can imagine that this
problem is exacerbated when you go from
its point 1 percent in the population
and now you're seeing it at 0.0% that
becomes a very large issue because most
sequencers error rates are too high or
PCR it's are too high that you actually
can't get the noise low enough to
interrogate
like that no it's really interesting is
when you do this with the reveal CT DNA
the blue line above is that relatively
speaking your allelic fraction is almost
unchanged it still remains above or
right at 5% where you would expect it to
be you do see a slight you know when
your decrease in the allelic frequency
here and I I believe that's due to the
the issue I was saying earlier where
there will be some fragments that are
either small enough and/or the primer
binding site from our chemistry is
actually near the end of a very large
fragment so you will see some
degradation there however it's it's not
nearly as big an issue as you would have
of an ample con based engine if
technology and what that allows you to
do if you look at the observed Balak
frequency of HD 17 invariance across
different molecular weight type or it's
very different input mass and different
allelic frequencies is that you can be
very accurate so you expect v one and
point one percent and then if we look at
this across many replicates we call them
five percent almost exactly one and then
point one three percent so we're very
confident that we're able to accomplish
as well so you know it's well and good
if you can do it on horizons sample a
synthetic contrived control it's great
if you can do it in theory but the
question is is really does this hold
true if I'm doing this from a patient
sample so one of my colleagues here
Brian kilo arranged this collaboration
with the University Hospital in Oslo and
what they did is they had a plasma
sample from gastrointestinal stromal
tumor and what they did is they pooled
blood from this person they isolated the
plasma they divided that plasma sample
and then they also took a tumor biopsy
and we wanted to see what does Archer
called they were at frequency versus
amplicon days versus what did we see in
the tissue biopsy so we used about 15
anagrams the library input at this this
particular scenario this was done as
quickly as possible within the hospital
itself and we tried to keep things as
controlled as possible throughout this
process right so when you go through and
you look at all these different kitten
you'll see no anywhere from about one
and a half to about a twenty two percent
made and then these are the unique
fragments versus the alternate officer
visions that we interrogated within that
sequencing room now when you take it
with the and Lacan based technology this
is where the problem starts to arise
that I was explaining earlier is because
you have a lot of that high molecular
weight background and cannot weed it out
like an ant Lacan based technology is
that you get this point three and three
percent or you get this almost order of
magnitude reduction in what the allelic
frequency is so a call that's relatively
easy for your standard variant callers
at three point two percent with the
archer reveal chemistry becomes
extremely difficult with an ample
accommodation method and now you're
looking for something at point three
percent which means you have to sequence
deeper to get through all the wild-type
molecules you don't want to read to get
the same power that you list on the
aren't you to do chemistry now when you
look at this in terms of the tissue
biopsy this is you know likely what you
one would expect and that you'll see
some that are present in both the tissue
biopsy and within the liquid biopsy and
then you'll also see the Rivera strain
so this person went through and
progressed on imatinib they acquired
resistance mutations and things of that
nature and some of them show up within
the tissue biopsy that was taken earlier
and some actually only show up as you're
taking the blood at a later time points
[Music]
so why does this matter right so like
I've been mentioning throughout this it
really matters because it buffers
actually variability so if you think
about all of that pre analytical sample
collection the key in really really want
to do is you want to take your blood
sample you want to extract the plasma
and the circulating tumor DNA and you
want to take all of that circulating
tumor DNA and you want to put it
directly into the assay right because if
you do any pre analytical steps let's
say like a cubed or a volume analyzer
measurement B now let's say you had a
hundred nano grams of material and you
have to burn 10% of that but ten percent
that's ten percent of the molecules that
you're throwing away so you're throwing
away you know potentially ten percent of
your positive molecule tempers
the background molecules and you're
really losing power so because we don't
have to worry about whether or not this
is going to be an issue we can just
throw things directly in video say and
this allows you especially if you're a
reference live or something along those
lines to be less stringent or sometimes
it can't be as stringent as you want to
because the samples coming in to you and
don't necessarily have control over
there so and the other thing of course I
was mentioning is it comes down to
sensitivity and specificity so because
we don't have to be or we can actually
increase the allelic fraction via the
chemistry upfront or the alternate
observation fraction what we can do is
that makes it easier on our variant
calling strain so for us we have to have
a very caller that can find it at three
percent sure our variant calls will work
down to 0.1% and I'll go through that
but our point one percent is a true
point one percent where you know a lot
of these other amplicon based methods
will struggle in that respect so you
know efficient capture is great if you
can get all of the molecules but often
efficient capture isn't really enough
right you need to be able to do what
we're calling your correction right and
this isn't something new in the field
we've been doing it for three to four
years and of course you know the leaders
and the academic fields have been doing
this for likely even longer so you know
this is an example of that where you
have reads that are on air corrected and
this is an in case of a pretty this is a
CSTR sequencing pileup what you can do
then is that you can actually compress
all the reads from unique molecular bins
and you can clean up the data like here
in the bottom right so I'll explain how
that looks a little bit later so I guess
you know this comes back to the root
cause so if we think about the eyelet
idealistic view of NGS so everyone wants
and yes to be I put in a thousand DNA
molecules over here on the left hand
side one in 1,000 DNA molecules contains
that variant of interest right then when
I take that those 1,000 molecules I
process them through library prep and
sequencing the sequence I can't get out
represents it one for one and perfect
so in this case one variant in 1001
percent very infrequent section however
that's unfortunately not the reality of
sequencing currently the standard within
the sequencing industry is most people
representing how many bases did I call
greater than Q thirty right so Q thirty
is actually a relatively high error rate
when you're talking about a low point
one percent of women frequency so what
that means is when I take my a thousand
DNA molecules I process them and I
sequence them is that ninety five reads
within that seldomly population actually
have greater than one error and only one
of them still has the cherry berry and
what that equates to is a positive
predictive value of only one percent so
what that means is actually 0.1 percent
is you know unless you can accept a
positive value of one percent is
actually not not possible so what do you
do right so sequencing that a lot of
people think okay well maybe I can just
sequence my way out of this problem I
just need no index but the problem is
the air raid on the sequencer that error
rate doesn't change therefore getting
more sequencing reads with the same air
profile does no good so if you look at
that in terms of a statistical model and
you look at the error rate and then that
relative to the sequencing death is you
have the errors here in the red and then
you have your true variance there in the
blue and then despite that your
alternate observations for both the
sequencing error and the true variance
of interest go up with sequencing death
because your theory capturing more of
those molecules from the population but
the problem is is that the sequencing
error tracks identically with the
variant of interest therefore there's no
differentiation between whether or not
this is error or if this is a true
thinning of interest so what's the
solution here right so if you start to
increase the quality scores you start to
increase the accuracy coming off the
instrument that's where you can start to
make an impact so if we jump from 232
cube 40 and we're still looking at the
same scenario of the thousand DNA
molecules
at 0.1% barian frequency were attempting
to detect now when we have 10 reads with
greater than one ear and so our positive
predictive value then jumps to 9 point 1
percent so if we go to 250 q50 the
problem gets even better now we have one
read with greater than one error at 0.1%
frequencies to work for trying to detect
with our one room with the true variance
so now we're at a 50% positive
predictive value then of course as you
can push this to keep 6260 allows you to
jump ahead right and this puts you at
the case where there's actually zero
readings with an error or with greater
than one error within this population
and now you can take that one read in
1,000 and you can have a hundred percent
positive predictive value and be
confident that the bearing you're
calling is adequate so like I was
mentioning improved accuracy is the
solution sure as you know things have
progressed in the NGS industry we
started here at Jeremiah and over on the
last row and we you know 224 was
sufficient for that we're looking at
germline whether it's heterozygous or
homozygous you know 50 or 100 percent
relative to the reference the 0.1%
background error has almost no effect on
calling those variants out of the
population when you go to FFPE things
had to get a little bit better you know
we were pushing for q 30 because most
people validate their assays down to
let's say 5% maybe some closer to 1 2%
but regardless the point one percent
background area mutation profile doesn't
really affect what it is you're trying
to accomplish when you go to the liquid
biopsy market and where you need to find
that thing that's at one in a thousand F
point one percent that's where you need
improved accuracy and you need that
higher essentially quality score so we
know at least as it been today and
there's been great strides made and I'm
sure there will be more that current
sequencing technology is too error prone
to support that so what's the solution
to improve the accuracy and the solution
is molecular bar code based
error correction so this is what I was
explaining earlier but I'll go into a
little bit more
so we have our thousand molecules and
within our thousand molecules
represented here on the left what you
have and this I can draw with this
little arrow here is you have all these
little different colored adaptors there
right so all those different colored
adapters would represent a unique
molecular barcode tag so now when we go
through amplification and we go through
sequencing we'll have multiple copies of
all of these different molecular or all
of these different unique molecules and
then what you can do is you can say okay
well now I have roughly you know whether
I have here five copies of the orange
molecular barcode I've been them all
together and now all these errors that
were represented I can actually call the
consensus from this particular game to
correct those reeds and now you get a
very clean sequencing read that has no
area that is 260 or even better than 260
and you can do this with the burying of
interest and of course all of the
different reads within that population
and that gives you a lot of power so
then what you can do and the goal here
is you can separate background noise
from the true bearing of interest and
then sequencing gaps are creating
duplicates to give you more power in the
error correction actually allows you to
increase the quality score and in turn
call true variance out from the
population so if we look at the
alternate observations needed per the
sequencing depth so down here at low
sequencing depth I've been down very
deep we can't necessarily air correct
very well and that we increase the
sequencing depth we're actually able to
remove most of those errors and because
we can remove those errors you get this
separation between the red which is your
errors and the blue which is your true
variance so you can be statistically
confident that your variant of interest
is true so let's look at that in
practice so if we look at that in
practice what we have here is this is
raw wound so on the y-axis is the
mutation frequency that the variant
caller is saying if we don't set you
know in a real a fraction cutoff of 0.1
percent all these black dots represent
you know calls that we're seeing within
the population it's probably very
difficult to see I'll try to highlight
it here but there's a bunch of red dots
oh those red dots represent somatic
mutations that we were attempting to
detect you can see some of them are
above the noise and then of course
there's some that actually fall below
the noise so of course if you didn't if
you set the cutoff low enough to be
sensitive enough to detect all of the
variants of interest then of course
you're going to have hundreds or
thousands of false positives with the
raw repopulation and then the other
thing that we actually highlighted here
you'll see these things are very highly
refraction these are germline calls so
my green arrow there points to the
specific germline calls that are
represented so the first thing you do is
if you err correcting err correct these
reads and you'll see the majority of
these reads actually go down to baseline
so when we look at the second graph here
below that our mutation frequency of a
lot of these different positions across
there's almost no error profile so these
are weeds are nearly perfect or almost
clean relative to reference you would
expect however you're still giving a lot
of background calls right so you're
still seeing quite a bit of mutation
calls that are represented around this
point 1% allelic frequency cutoff they
were attempting to a team so what the
next step that we took was we wanted to
look at error correction and what we
could do is we could use inform
filtering so there's a lot of things you
can do whether or not the variants
damaging whether or not it's been
reported in the exact database or
perhaps it's just a very low frequency
germline variants that showing up it's
coming from a different tissue type
etcetera etc then you can also make a
allelic fraction cutoff which in this
case here would say ok we're going to
cut it off at 0.3% so now you have
almost all of the calls that you're
attempting to make our actual true
positives and you know this is really
great you can see how much cleaner the
sequencing data is we're getting almost
no false positives at this point
however you'll still notice that there
are some things that are creeping up for
maybe these aren't at you know
actionable regions of interest but
they're still demonstrating false
positives in the sense that we're seeing
mutations being called right so what
that means is often error correction
isn't necessarily enough you really have
to continue to take it further to be
able to truly call out things with very
high specificity right and I think in
this market and what it's typically
demanding is that you can always go and
reflex to a tissue biopsy however if you
can take a liquid biopsy and you don't
necessarily need to worry about false
positives or putting someone on the
wrong path as long as you have very high
specificity the sensitivity can be
slightly lower to compensate for that so
what we decided to do or you know what a
lot of the smart scientists and
unfortunate enough to work with decided
to do is we wanted to look at outlier
detection so we could take all the
alternate observations at a specific
base and we could compare that to all
the adjacent samples and run so let's
say we're looking at India 47 on a more
that particular base position we have a
positive within that sample cohort and
let's say we have 10 negatives and the
10 negative the allelic fraction call
might be let's say you know five
alternate observations that's typically
the the noise profile so then we can
compare that to what the actual true
positive call was and then we can say
are these two numbers statistically
different from one another right and you
know don't focus too much on these
figures here right so these are just
generic statistical figures of the you
know galloping distribution and
different quartiles in which you know
one would use to assume the population
of the background noise which might be
represented as this belief distribution
and then the population of a true
variant which could be represented by
this red distribution or in the air
correct agreed then
the key is okay well what's the
probability that my background noise is
much different
or my actual true variant call is much
different than my background noise so
what you can do then is you can compute
a probability so you say how many
observations are how many also in
observations do I have to see can be
confident that that does not arise from
a likely background noise or a
sequencing error so in this case of this
particular probability model here is
that I would say that if I saw 10
alternate observations that would be
100% certain that this actually arose
from and then of course as I start to
see more and more ultimate observations
based on those distributions of the
background noise profile I can say I can
get up to 40 option observations in
which at this point I'm saying I'm very
certain that there's a 98% probability
that these 40 alternate calls did not
result or arise from the result of
background noise or sequencing error or
pcl area etc so if you look at that in
practice you can have two things so it's
very important when you're doing error
correction to have deep molecular bins
so if you think about if you have two
reads within a bin so these two reads we
know came from the same molecule because
they have the same molecular barcode one
has an error position and the other
doesn't have an inner at that position
that gives you no statistical power
because you don't know which one is
right the first read could be right the
second release could be right so you
actually have you don't increase your
ability to know that that base has a
better quality because you can't air
correct it and that's the you know the
the hard part about shallow bins and my
sequencing depth is so important now if
you have deeper bins when you have
deeper bins you can start to air correct
more so let me explain this graph here
because I think it's it's rather
important so on the the y-axis here this
is the measured allele frequency so what
we have is we have this is the measured
allele frequency in this blue bar so
you'll see these blue bars here at the
bottom and let me try to draw this for
you so
these blue bars down here at the bottom
represent what we measured within the
population the green bars so these green
bars are not bars but these green dots
that represents what's the background
only so that says across all the samples
that the cohort is this particular
position what we have is a background
noise oh let's say 0.02 percent allele
in frequency then we have a target so
the next thing above that is what we're
calling the minimum detectable allele
frequency so we actually compute this at
every position so now we know at every
single position across all of these
different bases that we're interrogating
we know exactly what is the minimum
detectable allele frequency so a very
quiet basis we might get down to below
or around point 1% very noisy bases
you'll see these targets go much higher
and maybe we can only call mutations at
0.5% then and really what what that
saying is so based on your background
noise where how much higher do your
alternate calls need to be so that
you're typically confident that the
variant of interest is typically or the
the true bearing of interest is
statistically different than the
background noise so you can be confident
about that so the last thing too is to
really point out on this chart is the
idea of this purple done so what this
purple dot is is this represents a 95
percent sensitivity level so you'll
actually be very confident nearly 99.9
percent confident that if it is above or
at that target that I was explaining
with the second black arrow there that
you're very the athlete very specific
about if it's above that threshold
you're going to call it as positive and
99.9 percent of the time it's going to
truly be a positive now will if you ran
that Campeau over and over and over
again you might miss that in the next
run or you might grab it in the next
room because that represents roughly a
50%
[Music]
now what we also outlined here within
the within the graph here was the 95
percent sensitivity level so this is if
our blue bar here rises above that
purple dot of interest what that means
is that 95 percent of the time when we
run that same sample we'll call the
variant as significant from the
background noise so you can see this is
actually pretty messy when you have
shallow bins and shallow then
essentially represent things that really
can't be aired corrected now if we look
at this in the context of a deep bin you
can see that now things change very
drastically when you're able to do both
the outlier detection and the area
correction so now if we see this black
line here that goes across the bottom
which I can highlight really quickly so
that it's a little bit easier to see
maybe there we go so that line
represents the point 1% allelic
frequency mark and in this case so what
you'll have is you'll look across here
and you'll see that when you have these
really deep end and you can hear correct
them very well your background noise
goes almost to zero where you can go
much lower than 0.1% allelic frequency
there will always be very noisy bases
where no matter how much you air correct
this sequencing noise at this particular
position is just so high via from
systemic or stochastic error that it's
going to be very difficult to lower that
background noise then if you go across
here what you also see is because these
dings are deeper and they've them
interrogated the 95 percent sensitivity
level compresses way down and it gets
much closer to that minimum detectable
allele frequency so that you don't need
as many alternate observations to have
that 95% chance acidity level now I
think you know the most important thing
to point out is you look across all the
positions in this outlier detection
graph is the fact that these blue bars
represent things that have very high
allele frequencies that we're measuring
right relative to what the background
population is but because they're blue
what that means is we're not calling
them as statistically significant so
despite this being much higher than our
0.1% threshold in which we're a team are
attempting to achieve we don't call this
as a false positive so what we set out
to do was have an assay with extremely
almost near 100% specificity rank
because the false positive is really bad
I think in this particular scenario
we're a false negative that patient
you're you know that person or sample
etc can kind of progress further on and
they can go into you know a traditional
tissue biopsy et cetera so what happens
when you get a positive right so when
you get a positive
you know it's screams out at you for the
most part right so it be detected allele
frequency in this particular sample here
if we look at this red bar in that
position here so that's what is
considered significant so in this
particular sample this one not only
passed the minimum detectable allele
frequency in which were statistically
confident but it also passed the 95%
sensitivity level so what that means is
in this particular sample if we ran it
you know probably hundreds of times we
would almost call that variant every
single time because we know our
sensitivity time enough to do so and of
course you'll see these two here where
we have very large or very high
relatively speaking measured allele
frequencies but because we knew in the
background the rate at that particular
position we did not call them a
statistically significant and I think
that's really colorful
right because false positives I think
are one of the biggest issues playing
the CT DNA market at the moment and
being able to edit them well is of great
value so this is just another way to
look it down and to think about that so
kind of like I was mentioning earlier if
we look over here to this background
noise comparison on the right you have
two gaussian light distributions and
normal-ish distributions you have your
background noise right and then you have
your variant of interest so this is what
you're actually measuring now what you
want to do is you want to separate those
two distributions as much
possible and you can do that throughout
life you can do that through air
direction so as we are get better and
better at error correction we have
deeper more uniform molecular bins by
optimizing PCR uniformity or capturing
more unique fragments we can start to
separate those two distributions and
what that will allow you to do is it'll
allow your minimum detectable allele
frequency to go down by tightening up
the background noise it'll also allow
your 95 percent minimum detectable
allele frequency sensitivity level to go
down so in theory what's happening is
you're able to become more specific and
more sensitive by addressing these two
issues so if we look at this in the case
of what you're positive so this is 0.1
percent
HD 780 sample even see that in across
all of the variants of interest we call
them all statistically significant
we were also more than 95 percent
sensitive across all of these different
levels there's actually one particular
mutation here in which we did not call
it as statistically significant and I
think what's interesting about that is
that this could actually be rescued by
increased sequencing depth to sample
this particular variant of interest
morning but what we like and I guess you
know the point here is that we really
highlighted the idea that we'd rather be
specific and sensitive right the acid is
still extremely sensitive and even at
0.1 percent is greater than 95 percent
sensitive at most position but when you
have increased sequencing noise
sometimes you have to battle grabbing
more sequencing depth to increase your
sensitivity and then of course a true
negative right so I want to be able to
take something that is a true negative
and I want to make sure that I never get
a false positive and you can see here
because we don't even measure an allele
frequency in all these particular
scenarios we're calling no variance of
interest the sequencing data
the Queen and you know that this is
really really really awesome in my
opinion so if we look at this in the
case of a monitoring application so we
can look at this in practice right and
so let's look at a patient that one of
our collaborators type Elliot the
University of North Carolina
collaborated with us on so we had an
EGFR positive patient here with the
variant of interest that listed there
we had a tissue biopsy so we knew what
was going on right we knew from this
moment issue biopsy that was the
mutation of interest this person went on
a tyrosine kinase inhibitor treatment
and then we started to or not we but
Peggy started to collect plasma at those
different points and then run the archer
reveal chemistry on those particular
plasma samples and we were blinded to
the fact that this but it was actually
very interesting in the fact that well
we know they went on tki treatment so we
knew what the biopsy had and we knew
that we would get this deletion within
EGFR which is clearly outlined here with
the IgG screen shot on the left which
denotes the deletion of interest however
what we also found is you know after
time on this DKI treatment is you can
very clearly see the two resistance
mutations such an EGFR t7 90 M and this
pick through CA and so we were able
without doing another tissue biopsy in
this particular case was defined and
resistance mutation of the interest in
this particular sample so down there I
guess the thing that popped up on the
bottom this is the output from our
analysis pipeline so all this came
directly from our analysis pipeline you
can see the allelic frequencies you were
calling and actually these allelic
frequencies and this is what we
typically see as we saw in the other
example I was mentioning earlier that
the oil fraction tend not be as low as I
think most people want them to be and I
think that might be partially due to
using a pro/con based technologies and
really amplifying things that you don't
want so you think that they're at point
one percent when they're actually at
three four five percent within
a pop taught excel fraction there than
160 bins kind of glaze on top fraction
so you know the last thing that we did
within that as we looked at okay so we
know the tissue variance and we have the
classroom variance and if we look at
tissue bearing it's greater than 5% of
the frequency and the positive variance
greater than 0.5% allylic frequency is
that you get relatively good overlap in
some cases you get almost all the plasma
there ants are located within the tissue
variance sometimes you get ones that are
unique to the plasma or you need to the
tissue
you know the biology I think the verdict
is still out on this one but it likely
has to do with the tumor
micro-environment you know which part of
the tumor did I biopsy versus what was
shedding at the time that I pulled blood
which I believe might give you a more
you know global view of what's happening
within the tumor of interest so you know
we call things down to point two eight
percent of the fraction we call things
as high as 44 percent in the case of the
center mass variant but in general we
had varying conclusions so you know
really in summary you have a library
preparation method that can work with
very low input amounts however of course
because this is a sampling problem the
more input you put in the more sensitive
your assay will be because the more
molecules you will interrogate and the
more likely you are to sample an
alternate observation from a background
of the reference population the
selective enrichment really allows you
to grab those low molecular weight
fractions which enhances our variant
detection because we don't have to force
our variant callers to make all the
point or two percent because we enriched
for that fraction therefore they're
making call that 0.1% of course we're
sensitive well below one percent with
the correct input point one percent is
certainly achievable or in some cases
likely even lower and you know I shared
some of the stuff we're doing today on
error correction our outlier detection
and of course this continued advancing
an archer this as well as release now
and of course we'll make strive to make
that better clean
faster to capture my molecules in the
future really with that you know I'll
turn it over back to our product manager
Jonathan he can talk about you know the
actual product offering that we have
which you know goes to a custom apps a
design so we have a team of brilliant
scientists that can go through and they
can design custom assays for us the
off-the-shelf product isn't really what
you want so with that thank you and take
it over Jonathan alrighty thanks Josh
so just to recap we're talking about the
reveal CT DNA 28 assay and this has been
designed to cover 28 target genes the
input requirement as Josh mentioned is
very flexible so it's designed to work
with whatever that use case may be on on
your end there are a total of 198 GSP to
amplicon so that's the total size of the
library and right now this is only for
the Illumina platform very soon we will
look to have this available for ion
torrent as well and we are recommending
five million reads per sample these are
the target genes that are covered by the
assay so it's 28 genes and you'll note
that tp53 is complete exon and let's see
here we we also had configured this
panel to make it very easy to customize
it and make it smaller so we realized
that five million reads maybe a little
bit high for certain sequencing
platforms so if you go to this website
here sarkodie XCOM you can access our
asset designer tool create a user
profile and what you'll find when you go
in there and create a CT DNA panels for
the Illumina platform is you'll be able
to pick and choose these existing
designs from the 28 gene panel and pare
that down to suit your particular
application and there's no additional
design fee associated with this because
these targets have already been designed
and they
they're all of the the archer
knowledgebase and designing and
balancing that panel and this is a
picture of our crazy crew so we're very
happy that you could join us today and
we look forward to working with awfully
all of you on your projects and your
applications and would like to send out
a special thank you to all of our
collaborators Peggy gully at UNC and
Leonardo it although University Hospital
as well as John I afraid Ian Longley at
Massachusetts General Hospital and with
that I will take any questions
Jonathan thanks so much for you and Josh
for for your presentations now before we
get started answering questions I want
to remind our audience that you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green CUNY button at the lower
left of the presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can we're really running or we just hit
the top of the top of the next hour so
we only have time for a few questions
but if we don't get to your question we
will address them directly with you now
just so let's let's go ahead and and do
some of these questions so Jonathan what
controls you recommend for this kit
that's a good question so there are a
lot of commercially available as
synthetic controls I think I have a
slide on that right here so the data
that we've shown in this slide deck was
using from the horizon HD 780 multiplex
CF DNA reference standard set we've also
evaluated the Sira seek mutation kit and
both work very well with this assay so
yeah that's what we would recommend all
right great
next one is there a particular CF DNA
purification kit that that you use or
recommend mm-hmm yes I have a slide for
them too
okay so the data shown here from our
collaborators was using either the pro
mega option shown here where the kyochon
option
I think the pro mega is probably our
favorite in terms of ease of use and the
quality I think of the extracted nucleic
acid and the overall performance of the
assay there's another one shown here
that also has a fantastic track record
just fundamentally of their technology
although we do not have any direct
feedback on this particular one but I
listed here also because of the larger
input volume that it can process great
thanks here's one I think you you you
you touched on this in your presentation
but the reiterate is C to be in a
chemistry work does it work for specific
tumor panel or is it used across various
cancers yeah let me go back to the
target specification so we designed this
assay in very close collaboration with
top-tier cancer centers and so they kind
of communicated to us their use case and
the the targets that they would be most
interested in having in a single assay
and different different customers like
to have smaller panels other customers
like to have larger panels certain
projects require certain target genes
and other ones are less less relevant so
what we designed here is what we're
trying to do is make a very flexible
panel that covers as much of the highly
relevant or interesting targets and then
just enable that for everyone else to
customize it and use the specific
targets that are relevant to them we
also can do custom outside of this 28
gene panel that however would bear a
design fee and there's a slightly longer
time commitment because that we'll be
working with our designer protein but we
have done that already several custom
panels and we're happy to do that
great
and then last question here can this be
used to detect amplifications
amplifications yes we we get that
question a lot and I went ahead and put
together a slide figuring somebody might
ask so it's it's a little bit tough
because it really depends on biology
don't remembers this slide still hadn't
the animations on it and see yes it does
okay so the issue of tumor cellularity
when you have maybe an FFP
slice and there's not a whole lot of
tumor sample present so the overall
cellularity is quite low and then you
have the challenge of trying to detect
an amplification when you have such a
small amount of tumor present and the
same issue kind of plays out here and
this liquid biopsy application so
there's the potential that this might be
useful when you have very high tumor
cellularity or when that relative
balance of CP DNA outweighs the the
balance of the circulating cell-free DNA
fraction so perhaps in in late stage
cases there might be some utility for
this and we do have some data where we
we did call a met amplification using a
synthetic control this is a horizon 786
and it works quite well even though this
is as we're showing here this is a very
hot spot panel and it's where we're not
tiling across the entire gene and we
were still able to detect the
amplification so in theory it works on a
synthetic control it works but there's
some complicated biology that I think
end-users are going to have to invest a
great deal of thought and care into
designing that into an assay mm-hmm all
right
okay so there's I have a few more
minutes left Jonathan do you have summer
ministry answer a few more of these
questions sure maybe one more okay yeah
let's see so this here's a question how
much did the cause for assay for the for
the archer materials and and I think he
he wants to see like for the other self
plus like added controls or with you
know with the with with purification
just stuff about around price grass a
yeah I don't have a good sense of the
total cost of the essay including
upfront extraction but the the cost of
the library prep kits which
includes the archer analysis software so
this is a completely configured solution
is two hundred and fifty dollars u.s.
per sample and depending on to the the
sequencing costed at five million reads
it depends on which sequencing platform
is being this is being run on and how
many samples can be multiplexed at one
time so there is an additional cost
associated with sequencing not not as
cost-effective on the my seek platform
we designed this panel really with
Mexique users in mind and it's it's very
inexpensive to sequence it on an X Igor
I seek great thanks Jonathan
so that's that's all the time we have
for questions as I said before we will
follow up directly with you if we didn't
get time to ask to answer your question
and if you have further questions or
follow-ups on on what Jonathan or Josh
talked about feel free to email us at
info at Archer dx.com just a reminder
this webinar is being recorded and will
be available for on-demand unman viewing
shortly and you will receive an email
from laboratories available and we hope
that you'll pass the link on any
colleagues of yours that they couldn't
attend today we didn't want to thank
Jonathan to Josh for the presentation
and and really also want to thank thank
you guys for for joining in this I know
you guys you know everybody's busy and
your time is valuable and we hope that
you found value in this in this
presentation so we'll see you next time
goodbye